hmm pretty sure no one ever asked for
this one but once in a while you just
gotta trust me
now the thor kinda sucks again revisit
the first time marvel brought their
golden boy to life so let's crack open
the honest trailer vault for
hulk vs thor
okay officially it's the incredible hulk
returns but we both know no one's
clicking on that
in a world dominated by movies like
superman superman 2 superman 3 and
supergirl marvel has surrendered film to
dc and retreated to the small screen
selling spiderman off to the japanese
spiderman
and using their only past success to try
and launch a new hero thor
look marvel sucks at adapting their
comics but do you realize what this
means they're setting up a made for tv
avengers movie so rad i hope they get
kevin kline for loki or george carlin
maybe cruz
six years after he wandered down the
road for the last time bill bixby
returns he's still a man on the run
hiding the true identity of david banner
under the alias david banyan my
organization kidnapped david banyan also
within the week was david danner taken
he's a frankenstein trying to perfect
his hulk's direct begun so that only
leaves time for him to do two things
science i've turned the transponder into
a kind of giant chinese puzzle and his
co-worker you smell delicious
he tastes pretty good too but when
banner gets angry look out no fabric is
safe from the hulk lou ferrigno returns
with an even scarier bowl cut and when
this monster bodybuilder finally comes
out to play he's showing off his
signature move grunt flexing
[Applause]
lots of grunt flexing
[Applause]
who directed this lou ferrigno's dad
what symmetry you got lou you know you
look like something michelangelo caught
on
since the 70s fans have wondered if a
live-action thor movie could work now
eric kramer has the answer
no
meet the viking god with a hammer you
know from the comics but instead of
norse magic he's got nose magic get
promoting this nose of mine always find
my man super cab healing powers
[Applause]
and an infectious laugh in that i think
he has some kind of disease where he
can't stop laughing
[Applause]
[Laughter]
[Applause]
[Laughter]
but in this universe even the mighty
thor vows before donald blake my master
waits in his metal chariot instead of
being thor's alter ego like the comics
donald is this dweeb who everyone hates
i like you blake but only when you're
asleep so when are you leaving and who
keeps thor stuffed inside his hammer
like a dog being crate trained do i have
your permission to leave until one
unforgettable honky-tonking
hootie-tooting night on the town makes
them best buddies
[Music]
[Applause]
there should be more songs about big
guys being big it really helps drive
home how big the guys are
do you remember mcgee from the hulk show
the reporter hot on banners trail no
well fine he was a relic of the 70s
anyways and in case you weren't aware
this is the 80s this is the 80s i don't
know what a good cause is anymore that
means it's time for high-powered
executives contracts deals negotiations
squash publicity stunts corporate
espionage compact displayers and because
the pc-90s are right around the corner
who would you prefer to be on our side
thor or a bunch of trigger-happy
deputies even marvel is starting to
realize it's time to add some diversity
to their cast you stupid cajun idiot hey
you're just as cajun as me man
but you're not here for characters
you're here for action and this movie
will get to that when it's good and
ready
[Music]
no wait
fill the show-stopping set pieces like
thor and hulk slowly wrestling around a
sparkle factory
thor and banner taking down a helicopter
that's clearly just not flying half the
time and marvel's brand new cutting edge
special effect slow
motion
[Applause]
wow that looks truly amazing it's too
bad everything else moves just as slow
[Music]
so enjoy the first of three made for tv
hulk films that could be the launch of
an interconnected marvel universe and i
for one am on board because who knows
what dc is doing with that new batman
movie can you believe they gave it to
the guy who made pb's big adventure and
it stars mr mom 1-800 not my batman
starring
where's the beef oh there it is i dream
of weenie a venge of this nerd a woman
scientist jay jonah lamason
and thor's drinking problem i'm thirsty
is there nothing to drink in this
alchemist's dead i want a drink mead or
what you call beer will do i
need to drink
[Music]
beating a dead norse
you know banner's girlfriend maggie has
a superpower in this too ignoring red
flags
[Music]
i don't think neither do i speculate
assume or hypothesize
eat my hammer
i am more disappointed than a polar bear
at a seal concert
would you like fries with that
and his name is john
cena da da da